I love the way that that Santa's journey
and did I think it was kind of the one
thing that she wanted throughout the
whole show was to be home and to be
where she felt most safe and comfortable
and that's Winterfell and she's totally
capable of leading those people since
she got to King's Landing in season one
she never wanted that iron throne she
never wanted to rule over that many
people I think I think her character
watching the way Huck this character
finished Game of Thrones was the most
satisfying ending there so I agree with
you I was gonna say yeah I love your
kind of rundown so were you good with
how you saw oh that's better
there's no and also the iron there's no
Iron Throne anymore first of all yeah
true but yeah absolutely I and I had
said that to her I was like that was it
was my favorite her and Ariane my
favorite arcs of the series hello Jean
who are you the better question is
my favorite thing about this movie is
how much you kicked ass in stilettos and
I love I mean that's how I kick ass
but it was so intentional a lot of the
shots you just step over with the heel I
said yes honey I was walking
[Laughter]
[Music]